hey if you want some exclusive anime
merch like this harem king Deku got a
Smasher mall
checkout enter dream world calm link in
the description what is up everybody its
Anna Mack here for anime off floor and
today I will be breaking down the most
recent developments in the boku no hero
epic war arc including the opening up of
the second battlefront inside the
paranormal Liberation Front mansion and
the official unmasking of the double
agent and traitor who made this entire
operation possible things are now
heating up on two separate fronts and we
can expect absolute chaos in the very
near future so let's talk about it right
now
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going please leave a like to let me
know it really does help and if you
happen to be new to anime or please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications also if you're not new but
you still haven't subscribed please
subscribe it helps us and it helps you
see more content
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers
we're talking about the latest
developments in the story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned chapter 2 6 3 takes us away from
the action at the hospital and the
incredible miracle versus high end
normal showdown not gonna lie I'm still
thinking about miracle and her
awesomeness in fact I'm probably
thinking about her a bit too much if you
know what I mean but I am also glad that
we are now finally seeing what is
happening on the other front of the
battle this second front is just as
important and just as much is at stake
not to mention all the pro heroes and
hero students who are involved in this
attack and whose lives depend on its
success we see Minetta Seto and a bunch
of other class 1a students hanging back
as reinforcements they are waiting for
the heroes on the front lines to assault
a deliberation front mansion and they're
preparing to play a supporting role if
it comes down to that Jiro uses her
quirk to check the ground for vibrations
and she informs the reinforcements that
the heroes are on the move the attack on
the villain headquarters has begun Minah
ties all like yeah that's cool we'll
just chill here and let the experts
handle it but one of the pro heroes
tells me a tie and everyone else to get
ready
the fact that a lot of heroes and hero
students were gathered here in one place
it doesn't mean that they had the luxury
of being complacent they still have to
be prepared in case something goes wrong
and in a massive and complex operation
such as this one things could go south
very quickly there is no way to know how
this battle will progress or what kind
of quirks the villains have at their
disposal so everyone even the
reinforcements must be prepared for
anything and everything
meanwhile Jia and Momo are wondering
about toka Yami and community and
whether the two of them will be okay
that's because Takuya me and kaminari
were among the very few heroes students
who were chosen to be on the front lines
along with the strongest pro heroes in a
particular community and toki army were
chosen to be a part of the front-line
assault because of their unique quirks
although it's fair to say that at first
community is by no means confident about
the plan and he is definitely having
some second thoughts he keeps talking
about how he misses class 1a and how he
should be back there with them not here
on the front lines exposing his life to
mortal danger the mansion assault
includes dozens of top tier heroes
including edge shot cimento Smout lady
conway woods and many more toh kweh ami
and midnight assure coming out that
everything will be okay and that his
quirk will prove to be an important
asset for their attack it turns out that
it was actually some mentos who created
that massive crack in the villain
mansion that appear at the end of the
previous chapter as we know cemento says
a quirk which allows him to manipulate
and control all cement that he touches
and cement os-- uses this ability to
nearly break the entire concrete mansion
in - and this is just a side note but
I've never seen some Mentos this mad and
this ready to go he definitely has a
pretty epic game face when he gets
serious and I certainly wouldn't want to
mess with that man if I had the choice
it's obvious in hindsight that cemento
says quark would be very useful against
the concrete structures such as the
mansion but because we've never really
seen cement hoes get serious I didn't
fully realize just how powerful this guy
truly is in the past when we've seen
some Mentos use his quirk he used it as
part of the hero training at UA so he
was definitely holding back now the
gloves are off and the power of cement
os-- cannot
be underestimated the man is a beast
skeptic begins summoning members of the
paranormal Liberation Army and he
positions them in various strategic
places in order to repel the hero attack
as cemento s-- uses his quirk to shake
the entire building from its very
foundation a villain with a scar on his
forehead and an electricity based quirk
calmly steps up to the plate as the
villains inside the mansion's scrambled
to respond to the surprise attack an
epic showdown is about to take place
between some of the strongest heroes in
the world and some of the most vicious
members of the Liberation Front headshot
appears to be leading the hero charge
and he warns everyone that their goal is
to apprehend the villains with that said
they all have to be very careful because
these are not some petty criminals or
run-of-the-mill street thugs these are
highly trained soldiers who are even
willing to sacrifice their own lives for
their cause this will not just be any
old hero vs. villain battle this is a
battle between two completely different
life philosophies and both sides are
prepared to do whatever it takes to win
as they approach the mansion midnight
tells community to stay focused by
thinking back to the things he holds
dear to his heart and concentrating on
those things instead of thinking about
danger and fear coming out he instantly
thinks back to his classmates who are
hanging back behind them and he also
thinks back to Jiro in particular common
area things back to how much he respects
Jiro's passion for music and how hard he
worked in order to help her succeed back
during the school festival these
thoughts inspire coming re to step it up
and do what must be done for the good of
everyone after all his classmates who
are hanging back and serving a
supporting role depend on the frontlines
for their safety if this attack fails
then the reinforcements will be in
direct danger and coming out he refuses
to let that happen as the villain with a
scar on his forehead fires up a Taser
and then proceeds to amplify the
electricity that was produced in order
to attack the heroes coming re is able
to use his own electric quirk to absorb
the shock of the villains quirk and this
effectively neutralizes the villains
attack and the damage that he was about
to do to the heroes it appears that this
villain has a quirk that can amplify but
not
generate electricity which is why he
needed a Taser to get things going
caminar he does have the ability to
actually generate electricity but the
outcome of this showdown between two
lightning users will depend on how
powerful the villains control of his
quirk is if the villain is somehow able
to take control of the electricity that
coming re produces he could turn caminar
his own quirk against him but if
kaminari is able to hold his own then he
can render this villains quirk useless
as he did in this chapter I have to give
props to common re in this chapter he
starts off clearly anxious and full of
doubt but after thinking about what is
at stake and who he is fighting to
protect coming re steps up and pulls an
epic mad lad move huge respect for
common re and the epic coming up from
Gurren Lagann pose that he strikes up as
he takes on the villain you can't tell
me this is not a direct reference coming
up coming re it all makes sense this
chapter also gave a lot of hope to the
Jiro X coming era shippers out there
when he was thinking back to his
classmates denk he definitely singled
out Jiro as someone that he truly cares
about sure this could be just a sense of
respect that he feels for a classmate
but it could also be more than that so
you know feel free to let the ship set
sail down in the comments the chapter
ends with Hawkes apparently attacking
twice inside the mansion twice looks
shocked and utterly betrayed as Hawkes
stands above the villain with fierce
determination in his eyes it seems that
Hawkes has finally revealed himself as a
double agent and those in the liberation
front like twice who had come to see
Hawkes as a friend are now in for a rude
awakening Hawkes was a spy the whole
time a traitor
a double agent and this entire operation
by the heroes could not have been
possible without the Intel that twice
had revealed to Hawkes twice is bound to
feel hurt and shocked at first but when
he realizes how hawks has betrayed him
and how Hawks used information that
twice willingly gave up to someone whom
he thought was his friend in order to
plan this entire surprise attack twice
is bound to absolutely lose it twice is
anything but mentally stable as it is
and it is quite possible that this
revelation will infuriate
him and ignite an absolute clone
overload Hawks might look like he has
the upper hand on twice right now
because twice is still trying to come to
terms with what is happening but if I
was hawks I would get out of there as
soon as possible twice is not someone to
mess with especially now that he can
once again use his quark to generate an
entire army of clones and if he isn't
extremely careful Hoxha's life could be
in great danger in the very near future
I'm not sure what exactly Hawkes is
planning to do right now but I do hope
that he will be careful or else he might
end up like Icarus and fly just a bit
too close to the Sun after all if
there's one thing that twice cares about
it's his friends and hawks just betrayed
him and put all his friends in danger so
it is on let me know what you guys think
is Hawkes about to kick some villain ass
or is Hawkes about to be in mortal
danger also what did you think about the
hero assault any quick battles that you
are especially looking forward to
finally has the Giro X common Ares ship
sailed feel free to give me your
thoughts down in the comments below if
you enjoyed this video you want to see
more boku no hero content on the channel
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications if you don't go through
the trouble of hitting the bell and
selecting the option that says all
you're gonna miss a ton of our videos
it's just how you do works you can also
hit me up on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar I want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime out pro patrons
for supporting our work and making these
videos possible with all the constant
problems on YouTube patron support is
more important than ever thank you guys
so much first and foremost a special
thank you to our the one tier patrons
the ones who rise above all other clans
including Ingrid ah a Lola Adam the
world Steelers the school bus Tyson
Queenie no acquired respect and Pat a
heffa and I can't forget our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings Eldred fitted ala beat alpha do
Anatoli kazansky on hell cruise
Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor otaku Timothy
Vargas Shawn dark Joe Staunton JCC Wacha
Barry Gucci and Jessica Kayla Fong if
you enjoy our videos and you think that
they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our page
and exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see us bass Cowboys
[Music]